BROUGHT IN BY THE DEFENSEMAN DE
ZOTTO TOWARD THE GOAL.
GRABBEBE.
AROUND THE WIN
OUT TO EVEN HALF ANY CHANCE.
SIX
THEING IT AT
THE NET, HE HAD THE PRESENCE TO
TRY.
NORRIS UP HIGH.
TURNED OVER
LARKIN IS TALKING TO FORSBERG
NOW.
GOING AROUOU
>> Ken: SWINGING WIDE FOR DYLAN
GAMBRELL.
A SAVED.
OTTAWA 0 FOR 12 THE PAST
GAVE A WAY.
SAVED BY GRACE.
HERE IS TKACHUK.
SOMETIMES YOU TAKE A WHILE TO
PICK UP ON A GUY,
THEIR OWN ZONE
.
ON THE FEELING A QUICK PLAY BY
WITH SUNDQUIST IN HIS OWN ZONE..
HE HAS FOUR GOALS THE PAST FIVE
GAMES.
HE DRIVES THE NET.
YOU ARE MAKING THE CALLS BEHIND
THE PLATE ERIC ARE THEY PAYING
ATTENTION?
>> DID YOU SKATE WHEN YOU WERE
YOUNGER?
>> I PLAYED FOR A COUPLE
WITH 45.
FOURTH AND ROOKIE POINTS WITH 45
.
SEIDER TO GET IT IN.
IT GOES TO LARKIN.
WORKRKR.
WALMAN.
.
FORSBERG HAS BEEN GREAT.
BERTUZZI HAS TO LEAVE HIS STICK
GREISS INTO THE TOP CORNER AND
PLAYERS AND DETROIT LIONS IT CO
HRONEK.
ONE TIME SHOT STOPPED AND A
>> Ken: LARKIN C CWAS OFF ZADIN.
THIS THING GETS TURNED OVER
AGAIN AND ALMOST MAKES AN
THE RED WINGS DID WIN A COUPLE
GAMES.